hi I'm Mattie bankowski and I'm lead  game designer of dying light today I'd  like to introduce you to our brand new  feature the legendary ring levels upon  maxing out one of your skill trees  you'll get access to legendary levels  from this point on you'll start gaining  experience points supports you let in  their levels in the new legendary skill  tree you'll find exactly 250 levels that  let you further develop your character  by boosting your damage stamina health  and more on top of that every 25 levels  you'll get access to player emblems  outfits and bunch of new weapons  legendary levels are available with  dying light and hence addition or as a  part of free updates for the vanilla  version of the game this is just one of  many new features coming to joining  light in February 2016 so stay tuned as  we will share more details soon thank  you for watching and see you next time